kelly a déjà eu hanna ll je vais tenter
de faire disparaître qu'elle tient dans
un instant et surtout de faire couper en
deux l'un des chroniqueurs ça peut-être
toi toi toi toi encore toi jean-michel
là vous avez l'air d'impressionner
je vous ai vu dans les coulées ça vous
avez vraiment travailler comment vous
l'avez travail est d'ailleurs le trajet
découvert le boulot ça c'est sympa en
fait je me montre je vais pas le faire
lundi oxfam est en tout cas j'ai essayé
de faire un tour sympa à mon image sauf
s'il vous plaît on est une émission
familiale est géré selon vous le voyez
général dès maintenant j'ai un super
tour en revanche très familial pour les
enfants salle elle avait préparé avec
vous
absolument je vous laisse deviner un
bonjour à vous ouais vous a senti très
stressés dans les coulisses
j'ai peur en fait parce que je crois que
je vais participer mais à vos côtés a
lancé un peu chaud ah bah quand même
c'est quand même ce soir même partenaire
de ce soir
la seule l'unique l'indétrônable kelly
mairie pour débuter la soirée
est ce que je peux vous faire
disparaître une bonne fois pour toutes
oui j'ai fait ma partenaire est-ce que
vous l'acceptez d'accord on y va tous
mis ses lentilles
[Applaudissements]
oneda
elle est selon lui démarrer leur mais
cela dit franchement qu'est ce que vous
faites pour faire disparaître le corps
est ce que vous êtes déjà passé une
soirée dans une cage
non pas dans mes souvenirs nice comme
vous ai déjà fait disparaître non plus
je n'aime pas un garçon non c'est une
grande première
non non on l'appelle sur les fait
disparaître des garçons mais moi en tous
cas de manière vraiment nous le raconter
peut-être bar longtemps rentrer à
l'intérieur contre l intérieur allez-y
alors ok pénétrer dans la cage
vous êtes bien installés à l'est je leur
fais du sud deux sans toi je fais rien
je bouge pas vous ne bougez pas d'accord
hop
l'année commence à se faire ça comme ça
commence bien vous êtes bien salée à
l'intérieur fouet ou les que vous
apporte un petit coussin peut-être à un
souci on peut même installer la
télévision par câble
croyez-moi bas avec plaisir alors que ça
alors on va descendre ce magnifique
tissu alors j'aurai besoin d'une bonne
paire étudiants swarup toc papa paddle
des choses elle descend ouais c'est bon
mais les messieurs dans un instant
kelly b2b dit va totalement disparaître
et j'ai besoin de votre attention il ya
une formule magique une non réalisés
dans un instant tous ensemble les
chroniqueurs le public est ce que vous
voulez que kylie disparaissent saleh
[Musique]
il ya une formule magique à cette
formule c'est à bras cadart qu'à kehl et
se transformera je sais c'est un peu
compliqué c'est une petite invention de
ma part mais croyez moi elle m'a
vraiment l'espérait d'attention 3 2 1 à
brac à dakar est normalement kelly a dit
hanna ll je pense que ça sent vraiment
le battait mince à 2,3 fap
alors bon à faire là vous êtes là vous
m'avez de partir alors véritablement
mais alors je pars complètement
maintenant mais je n a perdu qu a dit m
walfoot elle ne sais pas je ne sais pas
où ouvrez les yeux parce que tout moment
elles pourraient réapparaître et vous
aussi peut-être non moi non non non
c'est tertiaire on est en tout cas je
vous trouve excellent pour l'instant
vous êtes en direct
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]